how's it going friends buddy welcome
today we're gonna play another fan made
game it's really cool for me to see that
you bros are so creative enough back to
the biggest game how insane is that so
the game is called sky guy see you
really has a beautiful logo there
check out food if I become a row awesome
so we have the character length we can
be peopIe why is free to play in this
game
well why isn't he in every game so he
made the felix challenge which is the
most intense levels in the universe
we're gonna have to see about that one
but alright I'll give it a go level one
okay
amazing it says my name in coins I
always wanted that prepare for extreme
alpha okay well I guess we'll try again
then you have to slice the would I know
that
[ __ ] there we go yeah whoa whoa there we
go
what you tricked me how dare you put
arrows there I like all my angel wings
cuz I'm so [ __ ] Joey
there we go there we go hey yo o'night
look come on bro is that the bomb from
fruit ninja I swear to god that's the
bomb from fruit ninja what I fly said I
don't understand what are you doing
the bomb is right there how the [ __ ] am
I supposed to slice them yes yes botch
yes you can't always trust those silly
arrows well I will in this time I will
go oh god no not trusting those silly
arrows but I will be stay ok slice slice
I did it I did it see that wasn't too
hard I hope that is no big deal no big
deal at all
bring on the next challenge oh god it's
getting big it is getting there
all the coins gotta get I'll take that
one go into the portal it's about to
rain
how how does that oh god no no I betcha
BAM
is that really my face I know I look
like yes I doubt oh it's like I guess I
got ya right I'm gonna take you in the
butt in the butt in the butt girl
anybody here we go why do you have to
put bombs when I'm slicing it's like
life you can't just do that you can't
just do that
there we go don't you dare put a bomb
when I slice girl don't you dare put a
bomb way ash lives girl bonus not water
what does I mean what is he talking
about I get it I am the best player in
the world well I need three stars yeah
right there we go they have a slice get
the star slice get the star dies in my
eyes
it hurts out okay I do second try come
on come on Nick is that all you got
ha a blue star I mean red of course I
know the difference I did not skip
kindergarten because everyone made fun
of me there we go let's do these brows
before the pie challenge is made for me
baby I got this thing in the bag even
though I'm not have a bag but if I had a
bag I would put it in the bag because we
just barely oh mine craft a man God my
god it's just not man I can't stop
thinking about him I wish we could date
here we are
bye slice you up well it doesn't matter
cuz I'm [ __ ] MLG god dammit never mind
I guess one day I will be MLG bros and
that day is about to come for [ __ ]
sake
Oh God beef if Oprah was here please
stop them please stop the beasts please
I'm a rapper because I rhyme two words
alright I got these Peas I got you I got
you girl
I rock my world if you wanna be on you
one repeat no I wouldn't I wouldn't
don't FBI don't would everywhere slice
slice slice slice slice slicing so they
pay me be my BAE now might might be a B
is not my BAE you learn the difference
it's it's essential for life how did you
get this far in life that shut up oh
that by god damn it I said it again how
am I supposed to slide all this way
no man can slice this amount of word no
Manny Oh God oh so close
it is getting harder though Oh for
[ __ ] sake
what is bees doing in here for [ __ ] sake
bass bees please get it right I guess
someone had a bee as a Bey and that's
how it all started there we go just
slice all the bass and I missed the last
one slice on the bass slice on the bass
nemenyi Lilla jävla boys chorim today
opportunit actor a night many fun Headly
bet this jab left I'm swiping my finger
like I'm like I'm in a Nutella jar [ __ ]
me call this level expecting me off man
there we go there we go
yo yo yo yo bad soil don't you lie to me
I'm slicing like it's nobody's business
I'm fighting like ain't nobody right
Wood is my worst enemy I never knew I
never knew I guess that's
it all makes sense widsom a data barrels
oh my god I just realized Illuminati yes
oh my god I was so close so many times
why the clouds so angry like calm down
don't you dare whips me don't you day
whoops me girl oh god the arrow strikes
again god damn you arrow to more level
bros we can you tease own young girl
it's called the felix challenge if i can
[ __ ] [ __ ] if i can complete this then who
can who can maybe babe maybe may gain
maybe big can go
maybe you can't [ __ ] how yes yes batch
oh i was so close to the star so close
I'm not risking it all right games are
enough already
slice iPod and that's last level bros
the final challenge
goddamnit yeah damage is gonna be bad
why did you have to do that I'm going up
oh come on
nein ah slice up patch this is subway
party this is how it party girl going
through the portal girl don't know why I
did that girl but I'm saying up here
because I'm gonna win throw that bottle
what is going on no one knows I know
snow which I can but it's going on it's
the map repeating itself while I'm
supposed to go down
oh my god this is like life but not
really [ __ ] hell man
so die all based on bet dancer flee
again the ya know how do I good how do I
go back down how do i girls already
going back down back down looking at
near date there we go there we go go oh
never go girl
oh I'm gonna complete this [ __ ]
challenge Oh super I know wow [ __ ] you
you think you're beating me Hank I slice
i swear to god i'm slicing like an Angus
with a knife in his anus that's right we
go down girl
all the right decisions up in this [ __ ]
brofist best bro
oh they said bros Oh Congrats all Felix
challenge is completed you are now skill
in the art of flying
hopefully the journey was somewhat
smooth you deserve a brofist won another
challenge but arcade mode maybe you can
beat Felix himself don't beat me so nice
well out was the brofist challenge no
the Felix challenge very cool that
ebro's are doing stuff like this now
kind of insane like you bros in a lot of
ways you boys are so part of this
channel with the videos I make which
games we play and how I do with stuff
and I talk to you Bros in the comments
and I can read you whatever you do and
in fact that even the games I play now
are made by your bonus it's so cool I
love that so thank you for doing that
and a thank you for being a broke in
whichever way you are I love you just
the way you
thank you for leaving like in a comment
and a breakfast to your face put your
face on the screen right now and I will
preface it but the damn plays on the
screen it won't hurt I promise there we
go
r-right brofist